hello and welcome to this video playing
wgm who bomb she's always on that level
right it's like always 2 2 2 2 30 or
something forgotten the name actually is
no name ok ok so let's see what she's
doing she's clearly playing very well
and I often have um the one bus window
lingo I'm just being lucky I've got six
six point five out of eight games but it
doesn't reflect how the games actually
yeah the games were it games were
progressing so yeah this is not so great
i believe i think you voice good for
white
[Music]
I think this is correct and quite sure
this is the problem like is not really
active active in this position yeah
we'll probably get the porn back almost
no matter wat maybe 95 you know that I
have 22 other than d3 actually hmm yeah
okay let's see what happens she plays
that
so just 84 93 this isn't that great
really
but if I do this d3 is no good Renee
right I go week we knee three and i'll
pick this up next yeah and a six I go
route you one later getting the point
back I hope
[Music]
let's quit very ambitious yeah let's do
it on the move I don't know did it wrong
there normally you get the pawn back
very quickly and judges better huh no
idea but somehow I always have problems
against him so nothing new so nine to
five grab the bishop at least maybe now
she can go back actually
[Music]
just overlooking too much yeah
unfortunately I have night a form but I
don't know if it does all that much
Queen 86
night a form Queen a 6 Bishop f1 or
something I thought that that doesn't do
anything at the end I really have a bad
position here again ok let's go for
something on the TV side I don't know
what did i do here so how am I at least
stirring up some trouble Bishop before
probably something something like that
maybe first retention yeah doesn't even
take before but ok I can move the queen
with the tempo so this is not such a big
thing ok she will take you five so so no
tempo and I have no time great
just age six is good this possibly also
good
[Music]
check kind of have to check time warning
yeah unfortunately there is not much
night you for midnight f6 sense not even
a threat she's actually on f2 fantastic
now that'sthat's really i mean i have
six isn't even remotely dangerous okay
night see 196 might be some more
dangerous but you can also just move the
king I mean it still doesn't work she
can also take e 5 that also is fairly
clean
[Music]
and at least it is somewhat interesting
that might work check I don't know this
already would have been too much for me
to consider fairly dangerous at least it
looks dangerous check
unbelievable I'm this level position
check check check check check check wow
that was one of the biggest swindled
black resigns yeah this is a new line
which is good for wide width how did I
screw it up again so we five and then
you're supposed to play this and now 94
is better I will see one I had him they
didn't remember I mean usually you just
get default back in a better but she
really got this in that was well played
yeah the night should be five it was a
good way of playing this and yeah it
didn't didn't play well with not at all
this is already probably not great I
mean okay I can repeat with 94 maybe but
this is now out a 5 i'm just in bad
shape aah was ridiculous yeah this this
is not working I guess because of taking
a solid line and your technique
okay now I'm just lost can't play for
some check non-existing tricks so this
is like mine is a millionaire you can
take on c1 and ready certain there I
would have plagued this move but just
bishops it sticks it's easy to see
ghosts in such a situation but I have
nothing this also should should be
enough but I mean here at least it looks
slightly dangerous route d 7-15 here
ready yep it's lost but it makes people
nervous this kind of situation and the
check f7 already warned ok yeah and I
had to play quickly this was also
something it's already clear that after
Luke's III I'm back in the game so I
didn't didn't look all that much for not
challenger channel yet thing but this
happened to quite a bit against her
already she plays well and somehow um
this is convert the great positions she
gets ok thanks for watching